in bloomberg reports amazon wants to
shed Whole Foods pricy image the online
giant is reportedly expected to cut jobs
and change inventory to lower prices
an Amazon spokesman denied any job cuts
were planned Amazon announced Friday it
is acquiring Whole Foods in a deal worth
nearly fourteen billion dollars Whole
Foods shares jumped 29 percent after the
announcement and Amazon closed up more
than 2% but shares of competitors like
Kroger Super Value Walmart and Costco
plunged Megan Murphy's editor bloomberg
businessweek Megan good morning hi
thanks for having here so why do we have
this market reaction and what's going to
happen to these companies well you can
see how it decimated other retailers in
the sector and that's because they think
that this deal Jettas basis is biggest
bet 14 billion their biggest acquisition
by floor is going to do what he's done
in other markets which is he sees
inefficiencies he sees this as still an
inconvenient process of us going to shop
this is an 800 billion dollar market but
75% of families spending on groceries
still occurs at physical stores still
occur as a brick-and-mortar if he can
take that and move some of it online
using Whole Foods really exposing people
across the chain to Amazon's other
products Amazon is going to get more
into your life than they already are
we know groceries is the single biggest
revenue contributor to Walmart for
example well exactly and that's one
person they've really been battling at
Walmart has been looking on the flipside
they're very big in brick-and-mortar but
they've been working really hard on
their online presence to how to compete
with Amazon bringing someone from jet to
redesign it from tip to tail about how
they do those services for people but
Amazon is a beast in terms of spotting
markets where they think they can reduce
inefficiencies where they think they can
make it easier for us to shop and that
is what he sees here he's done it with
books he's done it with newspapers he's
got you now with the prime service where
you pay special to get movies delivered
etc so he sees this as a market this is
his biggest bet this is something that
people have said could be his biggest is
worse bet his Waterloo some describe
that or his biggest transport I bet yeah
yeah yeah he got a name he got a lot of
real estate he got a bargain as many
people feel I mean so the potential that
these whole food stores will now change
to become pickup centers distribution
centers whatever else I mean that's
that's the fascinating part of this
huge and I think it's more likely that
they'll be hybrid you have to say that a
lot of people call homes it's got a ton
of fans but it's also got a lot of
people who call it whole paycheck they
say it's too expensive
what's going to be fascinating to watch
here is how do the prices come down does
he change the mix of organic high-end
food does he try to attract more rural
consumers people who are less familiar
with the brand almost 60% of Whole Foods
are within 10 miles of a Kroger and he
sort of get more people into the brand
is he buying it more as you're saying
for the sort of high end or is he buying
to really democratize whole thing and to
use as a distribution point exactly
when you talk about in efficiencies the
story of retail and the labor market is
a dismal one right now in America
absolutely what are the implications for
the people who work at Whole Foods again
if you take some of those stores and
moves them into distribution centers
we're going to see some type of job
losses there they've said they're not
going to cut jobs they've kept the
existing CEO in but look we're moving
towards robot so we're moving towards
robots as robots in stores as well they
already have book stores they already
have parts that are totally automated
from the beginning to the end of the
process this is just the way things are
moving the u.s. is actually further
behind Europe particularly the UK the
automation of the the grossing sector
we'll see if he with all his genius and
what he's done in other markets can take
it into our supreme are better equipped
interesting point he said in a newspaper
article over the weekend that I've made
a lot of bad mistakes and only because I
was willing to risk bad mistakes that I
have the big winner I have you can't win
some without losing boys certainly
swinging for the fences here what Megan
Murphy big relaunch of Bloomberg
Businessweek Congrats on that thank you
so much for joining us thanks